quand on va commencer le printemps
l'hiver humide persiste et perturbent le
travail des 15 maraîchers du jardin de
cocagne de magny les hameaux certaines
cultures accumulent du retard ce qui
annonce en mois de mai difficile pour
remplir les paniers donc là les carottes
que j'ai semé début novembre elles ont
pas beaucoup pousser sont quand même pas
mal souffert du froid est là elles ont
facilement trois semaines de retard
donc normalement on devrait avoir des
fans quand même beaucoup plus grande
donc on va avoir un petit peu de mal à
faire la transition avec nos carottes de
garde qu'on commence à finir et
normalement
on peut espérer commencer à enchaîner
dès le mois de mai à la mi mai pour
avoir des carottes et là on va perdre
facilement un mois à coire ce n'est pas
dans le froid mais plutôt l'humidité qui
a retardé les plantations tout a été mis
en place pour que le jardin ne soit pas
dépourvu en légumes on utilise des
voiles de protection pour maintenir
maintenir nos cultures un petit peu au
regel ça fait gagner quelques degrés on
a les serres qui protège déjà quand même
un petit peu pour pallier le manque de
ce début de printemps les maraîchers
s'appuie sur les bonnes récoltes de la
dernière saison pour ces agriculteurs
une bonne nouvelle cependant la hausse
des températures est attendue dans les
prochains jours et le retour du soleil
est annoncé en début de semaine
prochaine